What happens to a can of pepper spray when
it's introduced to SCP-914?
Dr. Greer decided to find out.
Three unopened cans of Fox Labs "White Lightning"
brand pepper spray were selected for testing.
The first can was placed in the machinery
on the setting "Rough."
The output produced was several piles of metal
and plastic scraps, several puddles of chemicals,
and a puddle of oleoresin capsicum.
The second can was placed inside on the setting
"1:1," and produced an unopened spray can
of Fox Labs "Mean Green" brand pepper spray.
The third can was placed on the setting "Very
Fine," and the output produced was one miniature
chili pepper.
When tested, the pepper was found to have
a Scoville heat rating of over 300,000,000,
which would make it the hottest pepper in
the world.